I saw him on tv with the cape and the laser beams
I don't wear a cape on november 5th you're
about to meet the greatest warriors ever known
eternals assembled the marvel universe
let's finish this we'll never be the same
are you a wizard like doctor strange I'm super
normal there are no wizards, doctor strange is
a sorcerer. A sorcerer is a wizard without
a hat. That feels weird but i'll allow it.
marvel studios eternals rated pg13
Welcome back everyone this is going to be my
new eternals video marvel just dropped a brand
new trailer with a bunch of scenes of them talking
about doctor strange so i'll explain what's going
on and why doctor strange seemingly doesn't know
about the emergence or this giant celestial that's
growing inside planet earth for the past million
years threatening to destroy everyone and how this
is connected to the events of spiderman no way
home and doctor strange multiverse of madness
because those are the next two marvel movies
if you're brand new to the channel be sure
to subscribe to get all the videos i am doing
a giveaway for movie tickets all you have to
do to enter is just be a subscriber and leave
all your theories about the movie on the video
but marvel obviously just released this new
trailer where kitt harrington's black knight
dane whitman character just casually mentions
doctor strange when Sersi is trying to explain
her powers in the eternal's backstory to
him this is obviously a scene that's coming
right after the big deviant attack where he
gets saved and icarus goes full superman and
he's witnessing their powers for the first time
like wait a minute what the hell just happened
there were so many people on my last video
that asked if Sersi killed all the people on
the bus when she turned the bus into flowers
the only person that was on that bus was the
driver and that's the person that she picks up
and apologizes to so that's why the person is
sitting in the pile of flowers because he was the
only person on the bus so she didn't just kill
a whole bunch of humans the whole thing with kid
harrington's dane whitman character knowing who
doctor strange is like he mentions him casually
in conversation like it's secondhand knowledge
it's all part of the overall marvel phase four
plot they've been telling in the last couple
of movies they do something similar during
the shangshi movie right at the beginning of
shangshi he and katie are having drinks with their
normal friends like they're just normal people
and during their conversation totally regular
human friends casually mentioned thanos avengers
infinity war the snap and also the blip during
avengers end game saying that at any moment half
of us could just vanish without a trace die in
an instant and the way they play the scene is
kind of in a comedic way so the idea is that when
shengshi and when the eternals movie pick up in
the timeline of marvel phase four enough time has
gone by since the end of avengers end game and the
blip with everyone coming back that the shock
has kind of worn off on the general public as
kit harrington's character demonstrates this the
avengers characters who fought thanos and endgame
are all now pop culture icons like if you remember
spider-man far from home at the beginning of that
movie high school kids like casual high school
kids are just referencing the blip like it's
no big deal on their high school news outlet and
just to clarify marvel finally confirmed that the
eternals movie takes place around the same time
as spider-man no way home is happening so the
emergence for instance the new celestial growing
inside planet earth is about to hatch and destroy
the planet that's supposed to happen right around
the same time j jonah jameson is doxing spider-man
with the mysterio video and just spoil a warning
for venom let there be carnage really quick if
you haven't seen that movie so when the venom let
there be carnage post-credit scene they imply that
the timeline of that like where this post-credit
scene is happening with venom being transported
into the mcu is happening a little while or
around the same time as that spider-man far
from home post-credit scene is happening the scene
of him watching the news broadcast of jay jonah
jameson talking about tom hall and spider-man is
a little bit different from the video that was
playing in the far from home post-credits scene so
it's implied there's a little bit of a time jump
but around that same time so the whole idea is
that eternals takes place before spider-man no
way home in doctor strange's spell to erase
everyone's memories in answering the question
now why didn't doctor strange know about a giant
celestial that's been growing inside planet earth
for the past eon because it seems like it'd be
a pretty big deal like he keeps this watch list
of all the most dangerous things threatening this
dimension wouldn't the celestial be on that list
the justification that they're going with is
because of the way the celestial host irish and
the judge used their cosmic powers their celestial
technology to cloak themselves from detection that
includes being detected by technology like iron
man stark tech but also magical detection as well
so on one level the celestials are some of the
most powerful characters in the universe next
to cosmic concepts like eternity which is the
living embodiment of the multiverse in eternity
created the celestials the celestials then in
turn created the deviants in the eternals and
even when all the eternals are working together
at their maximum powers they still could not kill
a celestial their best hope is to either convince
them not to destroy the planet like please do not
blow up the planet or try to keep the celestial
inside the planet from waking up like baby go
back to sleep celestial go back to sleep everyone
just be quiet don't wake him up and in that first
trailer you even see some of their active cloaking
technology that they use to hide the spaceship
the only characters that would actually know
what's going on with the eternals would be
characters who are ancient themselves like odin or
other eternals like the race of the other eternals
that thanos comes from on titan thanos would know
all about the eternals but obviously he doesn't
care about that he's just there for the infinity
stones and secondly doctor strange has not been
looking for any secret celestials growing inside
the earth because the celestial host planted this
seed for the new celestial in earth millions
of years ago and it slowly feeds on the life
that evolves on earth over millions of years
just helping it grow it happened so gradually
the process was so slow that it never raised
any red flags and once earth's technology got
to the point where they could detect it if they
tried nobody was ever looking for something like
that with that particular energy signature
doctor strange is powerful enough that if he
did learn that there was a celestial hiding
on planet earth somewhere inside the planet
he could break through the celestial's technology
their cloaking device and find where it was
itches that has been so stealth this whole time
up to the snaps in the blip doctor strange has
been so busy with other major universe ending
threats like thanos and the infinity gauntlet
that they never really thought to look for any
celestials on earth and even though the other
eternals seem like they're trying to stay off the
radar kumail nanjiani said that kingo for instance
because he's trying to be this big celebrity this
bollywood star he has interacted with other marvel
characters other avengers characters but not the
ones that would be able to detect that he was
an eternal that's why they try to avoid contact
with people like doctor strange because he'd be
able to immediately tell who they were but because
spider-man no way home now confirmed takes place
after the eternals movie and doctor strange seems
totally chill in the trailer to make as many cold
weather puns as possible inside the sanctum
with all these snow drifts everywhere it's
pretty clear that the eternals are successful in
stopping this new celestial from destroying the
planet either stopping it from waking up or
just finding a way to just negate the threat
so the next big question now is going forward in
marvel phase four like during spider-man no way
home during doctor strange multiverse madness thor
love and thunder all the other upcoming movies
do all the avengers characters go running around
now in their movies having adventures and we
just have this giant celestial napping inside the
earth forever like do the avengers just go around
stepping lightly because the celestial is still
hiding inside the planet like a giant ticking time
bomb early theory too they'll use that dormant
celestial inside the planet in the future movies
as the catalyst for some larger avengers story
like avengers 5 or avengers 6 or a fantastic
four galactus story there are a lot of you that
have also asked if i think that the celestial
that's growing inside planet earth is going to be
galactus and the reason why i don't think that's
going to happen is because they say so much of the
movie is faithful to the classic jack kirby comics
i think the celestial that's growing inside the
planet will be one of the celestials from the
eternals comics but for instance galactus is known
as the devourer he devours cosmic energy contained
inside planets around the universe he doesn't
consume planets themselves he just consumes
cosmic energy from the planets and if there's
a huge celestial that's inside planet earth now
just chilling out that's kind of like the marvel
fantastic four equivalent of a giant space hot
pocket pizza time if galactus were really hungry
and looking for a snack earth would now be so
rich with cosmic energy from this new celestial
that it would be the easiest slam dunk to use that
as the concept for the reason galactus eventually
targets earth in some future movie i don't think
we're actually going to see galactus in the mcu as
a big character metaphorically and literally until
well after that first new fantastic four movie but
you can see how they're laying all these seeds in
this track work to set up bigger characters and
cosmic level threats heading into marvel phase 5
heading into avengers 5 other avengers movies and
this doesn't even get into the whole concept of
mutants in the mcu and how they'll explain the
x-gene mutation i've already done a few videos
about how the eternals movie is setting up larger
mutants in the mcu so we'll add a link for that
down in the description and at the end of this but
that's something that's sort of in the background
like mutants aren't a really big part of the
eternals movie the eternals movie is mostly meant
to introduce these characters and do some larger
cosmic storytelling tell you the true origin of
the celestials the origin of the mcu but post all
your theories in the comments below what's gonna
happen to this giant celestial that's gonna be
sleeping inside planet earth for the rest of the
marvel phase four movies into marvel phase 5. i'm
supposed to see the eternals movie sometime really
soon i think i can post my movie review sunday if
i'm able to see it in time my full breakdown in
easter eggs video post credit scene videos won't
post till after the movie comes out everywhere
in a couple weeks so make sure to watch the movie
when you do have the chance there'll be lots more
spider-man no way home videos coming soon there
should be a new spider-man trailer next week so
of course i'll do a video for that as soon as they
release it make sure you have alerts enabled for
my channel so you don't miss anything everyone
click here to learn how the eternals movie is
setting up x-men in the mcu and click here to
learn about the new hulk movie that marvel is
making now thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!